[Music]
just when our hearts couldn't feel any
heavier
we learned that john thompson has died
at the age of 78.
the man with the trademark towel over
the shoulder
the trademark intensity and drive to
mold not just basketball powerhouses
but to shape the futures of young men he
did it for nearly 30 years at georgetown
his hoyas cut down the nets in 1984. his
influence will be felt for generations
hall of famer in every sense for studio
j in atlanta
we welcome you to tnt nba tip-off
presented by autotrader
ernie johnson with charles barkley kenny
smith
shaquille o'neal and as we talk about
john thompson i feel like as
as nice as you guys look we're all a
little underdressed
so oh perfect there's one for you too
shaq
is it right side the left side right
that's one of those down to the
chuckster
thank you wow
a ton of bricks this morning you know
when i got to test this morning
the first thing i thought about was
patrick ewing
uh three guys patrick ewing the kim b
matombo
and alonzo morning three great men
not just great basketball player but
great men and there's only two
basketball coaches no disrespect to
other coaches there's only two coaches
that when you talk to their former
players they says he doesn't talk to us
about basketball he talked to us about
being great men
john thompson was first and dean smith
was second
uh and the first time i met both of
those guys
michael took me to play golf with coach
smith and i was so nervous
but michael always said he never talked
to us about kennedy said the same thing
many times
but getting to know patrick and those
guys john
thompson wanted to create great black
men and i'll always respect and admire
him for that
you know i i talked this morning with
michael jackson his old point guard yes
michael was among those family and
friends who were with john
when he passed last night and the way
michael put it he said he just
wanted to expand our world he said
number one that's the reason i went to
georgetown to play for john thompson
and he insisted you better go to class
you better be up on current events
not just in this country but around the
world and he said
they even went to etiquette classes
because john was
preparing them for later life and said
look when you go to a when you go to a
dinner somewhere
i want you to know which fork to use and
which
glass is yours and that kind of thing it
was that
it was that outside the basketball world
kind of mentality that made him so
special to
to anybody who played for him when i was
13 14 years old it's a couple of
defining moments that
made me say i want to play basketball
the first moment was when
dale brown came to wildflick in the army
base
i asked him to send me something on you
know getting stronger he sent that
second moment was when ford mcmurtry and
chris woodard said
hey this is who you got to play like i
want you to watch this coach i want you
to watch this player
john thompson and patrick ewing so kind
of that's why i always wore number 33 in
case you guys didn't know
and you know just you know watching them
too and watching how he interacted with
the players
uh and then you know went to texas and
you know had already made my decision
about
going to lsu but if i didn't play for
dale brown
i think i can honestly say i would love
to play for john thompson and then when
i met him
he was just so nice and to hear john
thompson say big man i like the way you
play you're a great player
it just you know made me you know feel
pretty good and he was always nice to me
and
he reminded me of you ernie in this
sense he was the only guy that
that when commentating the games he
stuck up for the big guy
he wasn't bashing like certain other big
guys bad you always say hey he's getting
fouled he's doing this he's doing that
and then when i met him
i think the last time i saw him was at
the hall of fame without robinson but
you know my condolences goes out to his
family i was you know uh
had a pretty good relationship with his
son you know we used to do a lot of work
together but he was
he was a great man yeah i